listen not all heroes wear capes but
this past year we certainly learned that
many of them wear
white coats doctors are among the people
who have put their own lives
on the line to save those around them
however the new york times reports that
only
five percent of american physicians
are black and only two percent
of them are black women and disease does
not discriminate and nor
should the health care field and that's
why a team of doctors from north
carolina started a foundation
called white coats black doctors
to encourage more black men and women to
study medicine
and to provide financial aid to those
black medical students
so here to tell us about it are its two
founders
please welcome internal medicine doctor
janae powell
and obgyn dr celeste greene
hi ladies hi thank you so much for
having us
um dr powell what was the moment that
inspired you to just start this
foundation
so back in 2015 a group of medical
students
traveled to new orleans for the for a
medical education conference
um and on our way down there actually dr
green had the idea to
print up these t-shirts basically from a
mall kiosk
that had white coats black doctors on it
which was
the name of our group me that our
medical school class sort of
communicated about things going on at
the school and so
we had these shirts on and basically it
was a way for us to sort of celebrate
you know our achievements thus far and
sort of let everyone know who we were
um and so once we all have the shirts on
and we're literally walking down bourbon
street we had
um bystanders fellow medical students
that were attending the conference
physicians and just other people that
kept stopping us and were like
hey where did you get these t-shirts we
really love them
can we have some can we buy them and so
we started sort of taking down names and
numbers and figured out how to get the
get the t-shirts out there
and then once the money started coming
in the five of us founders sort of sat
down and thought about what it was
that we wanted to do with the money and
i think all five of us being
first-generation physicians
and having looked back on our road and
trajectories
into medicine really thought that
starting this foundation would be a
great way to give back to other young
students like us
um which we do in the form of
scholarships i love that
and it just also shows like if you build
it they will come if you
put a logo on it it's real and this is
just such a great way to incentivize
people to just start
um dr greene why do you think that there
is such a lack of black women and male
doctors
i think it's a great question and it's
my belief is is that it's really only
due to a lack of
opportunity and a lack of support or
encouragement
and it's not just my belief there's data
to support that
we know that black students
young students like school-age children
have they're more likely to be at
schools with limited resources
they are less likely to be enrolled in
stem courses or
summer enrichment programs that pipeline
as we call it in
in medicine and medical education the
pipeline to
medical education is is not a very
um continuous one when it comes to
minority students
that can be because of lack of
opportunity and lack of
access but also i think what's hugely
important
is the lack of support and lack of
encouragement for
that little black girl or little black
boy who might
might not see a black physician for
their entire upbringing um and then
when they go to the doctor as a young
adult they might not have a black
physician and
who can they turn to for encouragement
or who can they turn to to say
how do i get in your shoes if they don't
see it and so for
us for white coats black doctors the the
phrase that i like to say is that our
visibility
is our activism and so being out in
public
wearing our t-shirts and our polos and
uh
selling sweatshirts and all those things
it's not just to
make money it's to make sure that there
are people who see us and know this is
achievable
well i mean you've supported hundreds of
men and women on their way
to wearing white coats like you and
we actually have a special message from
some of those doctors and medical
students that you've inspired take a
look
i want to thank white coats black
doctors for allowing me to connect with
doctors that i could relate to and who
look like me you can't be what you can't
see
and so organizations like white coats
black doctors
are so important for increasing
representation
having that kind of extended support
system is so
important i want to thank them for the
award back in 2017 that completely
covered the cost of my mcat
that was a major financial burden that
was lifted off of my shoulders the match
day is coming up
next week where i'll actually get to
find out where i'll be
starting my career as the first
physician in my family
once again thank you thank you white
coast black doctors for valuing my
perspective
as a future health care administrator it
is because of my engagement with white
coast black doctors
that i will be the very first black
physician
in my family despite everything that's
going on with covert 19 i would not
trade my role as a doctor
for the world
i'm looking at all the people in your
video and you guys
you're all so wonderful and beautiful
and inspiring
and you are helping people see it
and this is so important what you are
doing and we're all so inspired by it
and um you know you're bringing that
diversity gap
to the medical field and trying to close
it
and give people that visual that they
belong to
and i want to thank our producer hariana
who got 5 000
to donate to your foundation to help
support
your medical students and i want to
match it so that'll be 10
000 to the
white coats and black doctors that is
incredible
i i'm at a loss for words um thank you
for the opportunity to talk about this
passion project of ours that
um it's it's changed our lives for me
it's been
probably one of the biggest things i've
i've ever accomplished and
one of my my most proudest
accomplishments and so it is um
really special to be recognized for that
thank you of course and
we want to put uh you know white coats
black doctors up on our website so that
if anybody would like to donate
and help further this cause of what dr
powell and dr green
are doing i think this is a vital
mission
and i'm blown away by the people that
you have had rise up
um you're just incredible and we're
honored to be able to
share the spotlight with you shine a
light on what you're doing
and help support it we want to continue
that you're incredible
thank you so much thank you so much
you